Hä?
We are live!
Manuel, Manuel, Manuel.
(Cari.)
Ich mal gerade ein Bild für dich.
(Für mich?)
Guck mal, fast fertig.
Zweihundert, ein goldenes Zweihundert.
Ja, ist eigentlich orange, aber für dich
ist es auch gold, Manuel.
Wir feiern heute, wir beiden, habe ich gehört.
Jo, zweihundert Podcast-Episoden.
Das ist doppelt so viel wie einhundert.
Ich habe es ja sonst nicht so mit Jubiläen.
Wir feiern heute, weil zweihundert ist irgendwie
eine schöne Nummer.
Ich habe mir ein Bier mitgebracht, Manuel.
(Ich auch.)
Das mache ich jetzt mal auf.
Ich habe es mir nämlich schon fast gedacht,
dass du dir was mitbringst.
Dann würde ich sagen, wir stoßen jetzt erst
mal mit uns beiden und mit euch da draußen
an.
Prost!
(Prost!)
Auf unsere zweihundertste Episode des Easy
German Podcast.
Ja, wir haben uns …
Manuel.
Etwas ziemlich Verrücktes überlegt heute.
Es war deine Idee.
(Ja.)
Und zwar haben wir ja in diesen zweihundert
Episoden schon so einige Gäste bei uns gehabt,
viele Freundinnen und Freunde und nette Menschen.
Und wir dachten, wir rufen die heute alle
mal an.
Und zwar wirklich alle.
(Also fast, ja.)
Fast.
Fast all… alle, die gesagt haben, sie können
heute Abend angerufen werden.
Und wollen wir einfach direkt starten?
Ja, Manuel, ich würde kurz einsteigen mit
einem kleinen sprachlichen Hintergrund.
Und zwar ist das ja ein interessantes Thema,
das Telefonieren.
Und ich muss sagen, dass ich das zum Beispiel
in den Sprachen, die ich gelernt habe in der
Schule, nicht so gut gelernt habe, weil das
lernt man ja erst dann, wenn man es macht.
Und ich weiß, dass viele Leute, die nach
Deutschland kommen und Deutsch lernen, auch
ein bisschen Angst vor dem Telefonieren haben.
Das ist ja so ein Moment, wo man nervös wird.
Und deswegen dachten wir, wir machen das heute
mal, wir kombinieren das, Sprachenlernen mit
dem Feiern.
Wir rufen all unsere Freunde an und ihr lernt
dadurch auch ein bisschen, wie man eigentlich
am Telefon spricht, zumindest informell.
Wir haben heute keinen formellen Kontakt dabei.
Manuel, wie meldest du dich denn am Telefon,
wenn das jetzt bei dir klingelt?
Du gehst ran, du nimmst den Hörer ab, was
hört man dann?
Meistens sage ich tatsächlich einfach: "Hallo",
das ist aber nicht sehr typisch deutsch, glaube
ich.
Ich weiß, dass du dich anders meldest.
Hallo?!
Ich bin tatsächlich sehr formell, ja, ich
sage: "Carina Schmid?"
Und dann, gestern habe ich nur gehört: "Hallo,
hier ist Aki!"
Genau, den rufen wir gleich auch noch an.
Ja, wir schauen mal, wie sich die Leute gleich
melden.
Ein paar Leute sind sogar per Videotelefonie
dabei und ich würde sagen, wir starten einfach
mal mit dem Ersten.
Und wer könnte das ander(e)s sein als … Janusz!
Oh!
So.
(Prost!)
(Janusz.)
Prost, ihr Lieben!
Wie geht es dir?
Was ist?
Oh, mir geht es blendend.
Mir geht es sehr gut.
Ich freue mich mit euch und ja, alles Gute
auf de(m) ganzen weiteren Weg für euch.
Das war nett.
Danke schön, Janusz.
Danke!
Du bist, du hältst, glaube ich, den Rekord
für die meisten Gastauftritte oder Auftritte.
Du bist ja nicht wirklich ein Gast, sondern
ein Teil des Teams.
Ja, genau.
Ich wollte gerade protestieren, genau.
Ich fühle mich (als) so ein ganz klitzekleine(r)
Teil von eurem Podcast.
(Ein großer Teil.)
Aber tatsächlich ein …
Du bist ein sehr großer Teil.
Die Leute lieben dich, du bist der heimliche
Star der Sendung, Janusz.
Och ja, und das ist all meine ganze Freude.
Gestern fuhr ich mit meinem Fahrrad durch
Berlin Mitte und die Jungs, die das Essen
ausfahren, schrien mich mit "Janusz!"
an.
Zwei, ja, aber getrennt, und das war so nett.
Ich fahre da mit meinem Fahrrad und plötzlich
einer: "Ey, Janusz!"
Es ist (eine) unglaubliche, wunderschöne
Begegnung, so, ja.
Darüber freuen wir uns immer sehr.
Wenn ihr uns auf der Straße seht in Berlin,
schreit gerne mal: "Hey, Cari!
Hey, Manuel!
Hey, Janusz!", dann freuen wir uns.
Ja.
Janusz, wir müssen heute ganz schnell ganz
viele Leute anrufen, deswegen haben wir nur
noch eine Frage für dich, wenn das okay ist.
Und zwar: Wie meldest du dich am Telefon?
Das machst du nämlich auch ganz interessant.
Wie hast du das gelernt, wie macht man das
in Deutschland?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich früher mich mit
"Hallo?"
gemeldet oder … oder mit einem Gag, ich
… mit einem falschen Namen, so: "Hallo?
Władysław Broniarek hier!"
Und das hat mich, das hat mir aber Manfred
Sellmayer ausgetrieben.
Der hat mich einmal gestellt und Sel… Manfred
Sellmayer war ein Lehrer, mit dem wir zusammengearbeitet
haben, ein super netter Kerl.
Und er hat gesagt: "Janusz, in Deutschland
macht das nicht, macht man das nicht."
Und dann hat er mir beigebracht, wie man sich
in Deutschland meldet, nämlich mit dem Vornamen
und Nachnamen.
"Janusz Hamerski, bitte?"
So sieht es aus.
Ja.
Also, Manuel macht ja trotzdem immer noch
"Hallo", ne?
Aber …
Ja, weil Manuel sich nicht so ganz deutsch
fühlt, weil er ja fünfzig Prozent vom, von
der ganzen Weltreise kommt.
Genau.
Das ist der Grund.
Ja, gut!
Danke schön, Janusz.
Ja, danke schön euch und ich bleibe jetzt
als Zuschauer dabei.
Das freut uns!
Super, danke schön, Janusz!
Bis gleich!
(Ciao.)
Ihr könnt euch nat… uns natürlich auch
Kommentare schreiben, hier live auf YouTube.
Und wir haben schon einen Kommentar bekommen
von Jin und sie schreibt: "Caris Ton ist etwas
lauter."
Ich habe den jetzt etwas leiser gemacht und
ihr könnt uns mal schreiben, ob es jetzt
besser ist.
Vielleicht bin ich auch zu nah am Mikrofon,
Manuel.
Was sagst du?
Zu nah am Mikrofon kann man gar nicht sein.
Hallo!
Isi schreibt: "Es ist besser geworden."
Das freut uns sehr.
Manuel, wen rufen wir denn als Nächstes an?
Ich würde sagen, ich habe jetzt hier mein
Telefon, wir rufen jetzt mal die Marit an.
Die war ja in zwei Episoden vor nicht allzu
langer Zeit hier zu Gast.
Und mal schauen, wie sie sich meldet am Telefon.
Hallo?
Hallo Marit!
Ach, hallo Manuel, hallo Cari!
(Na?)
Was machst du gerade?
Ich habe den ganzen Tag an meiner Steuererklärung
gesessen.
Oh nein!
Das ist nicht so einfach als Künstlerin,
oder?
Nein, es geht, es war … ist okay, aber jetzt
bin ich fertig.
Juhu!
Das sind gute Nachrichten.
Und was macht ihr so?
Marit, wie meldest du dich normalerweise am
Telefon?
Du hast gerade "Hallo" gesagt, weil du wusstest,
dass Manuel anruft, aber wenn eine unbekannte
Nummer da ist, was machst du dann?
Dann sage ich meinen vollen Namen und ich
sage … was sage ich denn?
Ich sage: "Hallo, hier ist Marit Persil?"
Ja.
(Das klingt gut.)
Meinen ganzen Namen.
Das klingt auch direkt wie eine Aufnahme,
weil deine Stimme einfach so gut klingt, als
wäre das eine Bandansage.
Das könntest du vielleicht auch noch so als
zusätzliches Sprecherbusiness, so, wie heißt
das?
Anrufbeantworter-Sprachansagen, professionell.
Geil.
Ja, gerne.
Braucht ihr eine?
Hallo, ihr habt Manuel und Cari erreicht.
Willkommen beim Easy German Podcast.
Bitte sprecht nach dem Piep.
Piep!
Das nehmen wir direkt so, müssen wir nur
noch unser Lachen rausschneiden.
Sehr gut.
Das wäre perfekt, Marit.
Ich glaube, das ist noch mal eine ganz neue
Businessidee.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass einige
von unseren Zuhörer*innen und Zuschauer*innen
das auch gerne hätten, so eine Bandansage
von dir.
Ja, super, einfach eine E-Mail schicken.
Das klingt gut, Marit.
(Gut!)
Marit, wir wünschen dir einen wunderschönen
Abend.
(Danke.)
Danken dir sehr für alles, was du für uns
tust und getan hast.
Und wir hoffen, dass wir dich bald wiederhören.
Ja, sehr gerne.
Macht es gut, ihr zwei!
(Ciao!)
Ciao, Marit!
(Tschüss!)
Da wird knallhart aufgelegt, Manuel.
(Knallhart.)
Ich finde, das ist eine Wahnsinnstechnik,
dass du hier anrufst und wir hören das direkt
hier im Podcast.
Das ist ja …
Ist ein bisschen wie im Radio, oder?
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Können wir jetzt auch unbekannte Leute anrufen?
Klar, sag mal irgendeine Nummer.
Nee, das machen wir nicht.
Okay.
Ich kenne da wen, den würde ich gerne als
Nächstes anrufen.
Der heißt … mal sehen, wie er sich am Telefon
meldet.
Vielleicht sagt er: "Brenken, hallo?"
Oder vielleicht sagt er auch: "Klack, klack,
klack, klack, Klapper-Klaus?"
So nennen wir ihn manchmal.
Kennst du den … warten wir mal ab.
Ja bitte?
Hallo!
(Hallo!)
(Hallo Klaus!)
Du, ist grad ein ganz schlechter Augenblick.
Könnt ihr noch, gleich noch mal anrufen?
Machen wir, kein Problem.
Okay.
Das ist … jo, das ist hier live.
Bis später!
Bis gleich!
(Ciao.)
Ciao!
(Gut.)
Ja, das war ein schlechter Augenblick.
Dann rufen wir wen anders an, Manuel.
Rufen wir wen anders an.
Möchtest du ihn kurz vorstellen oder rufen
wir erst mal an?
Rufen wir als Nächstes vielleicht Hamed an.
Hamed war schon längere Zeit, vor längerer
Zeit bei uns, das war in Episode 56 und 57.
Und ich freue mich, wenn wir ihn mal hören
können.
Hören wir ihn oder sehen wir ihn?
Wir hören ihn.
Hoffentlich.
Hamed, hallo?
Hallo!
Hallo Hamed!
Hi!
Grüßt euch.
Wie schön, dich zu hören.
Wie schön, mal wieder bei euch zu sein, dabei
zu sein.
Ich freue mich.
Ja, lang ist es her.
Wie geht es denn dir?
Das stimmt.
Ja alles Gute, ich freue mich mit.
Herzlichen … (Danke schön.)
Genau, herzlichen Glückwunsch zur zweiten
oder zweihundertsten Podcastfolge.
Das ist ja großartig.
Zweihundert Folgen.
Ich muss das mal fertig malen hier, mein kleines
Schild.
Hamed, was machst du denn heute so?
Erzähl doch mal was aus deinem Alltag.
Ich war heute im Homeoffice.
Ich habe von zu Hause gearbeitet und jetzt
habe ich Feierabend, ich koche mir was.
Es gibt Nudeln mit Spinat und Lachs.
Schade, dass ihr nicht in der Nähe seid,
sonst … ja.
Wir wären vorbeigekommen.
Genau, das würde mich sehr freuen.
Und guckst du gleich noch Fußball, Hamed?
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich bin Deutschland-Fan.
Danke schön, das freut uns.
Immer, also, das wird nie anders sein.
Das ist toll.
Ja, Hamed, ist total schön, dich mal wiederzuhören.
Ich hoffe, dass wir uns auch mal wieder sehen
vielleicht, nach Corona, denn wir haben uns
auch bestimmt zwei Jahre nicht live gesehen.
Wie so viele Menschen.
Das stimmt.
Das hoffe ich auch, und ja, wer weiß?
Vielleicht sehen wir uns ganz bald, wenn es
mit mir bei der Bewerbung in Berlin klappt.
Dann werde ich sehr nah sein.
Oh wow, du bewirbst dich in Berlin?
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich möchte sehr gerne in Berlin arbeiten
und auch wohnen.
Wir drücken dir die Daumen.
Das ist nett, danke schön.
Das wäre schön.
Hamed.
(Toll, Hamed!)
Schön, dich zu hören, und bis bald!
Jo, bis bald, macht's gut!
Ciao.
(Ciao.)
Ich liebe das, das ist total geil, einfach
Leute anzurufen, während man live auf YouTube
ist.
Irgendwie hat das so was Radiomäßiges.
Ich finde das …
Ja, es ist völlig verrückt, ne?
(Ja.)
Wir haben hier einige Fragen bekommen, und
zwar schreibt Mariska: "Wie ist deine Impfung
gelaufen?"
Danke für die Frage, Mariska.
Ich habe extra mein Pflaster draufgelassen,
denn ich wurde gestern geimpft.
Guck mal, Manuel.
(Wow.)
Das sieht man nicht so richtig.
Ich hatte schon Sorge, dass du womöglich
ausfällst aufgrund von Nebenwirkungen.
Guck mal, sieht man das?
Da ist so ein kleiner Hund auf dem Pflaster.
Ich glaube, das sind Kinderpflaster, die hatten
sie noch beim Arzt und die mussten sie loswerden.
Und ja, ich freue mich sehr, ich bin jetzt
geimpft, Manuel.
Nice, ich gratuliere.
Ja, der nächste Gast ist auch ein Celebrity.
Tatsächlich hält er den Gastrekord an Episoden,
vier Episoden.
Er war auch unser erster Gast hier im Podcast.
Und das ist natürlich Emanuel.
Hallo Emanuel!
(Hallo!
Hallo Leute.)
Das ist jetzt besonders praktisch für alle
Leute, die immer Manuel und Emanuel verwechseln.
Jetzt sehen sie euch mal beide zusammen.
Wie schön, dich zu sehen, Emanuel.
Ja, euch auch!
Du siehst frisch aus.
(Danke schön.)
Warst du beim Friseur?
Nee, aber ich war beim Sport.
Welcher Sport?
Ich war im Fitnessstudio heute.
Pumpen.
Cari macht gerade vor, wie man Muckis zeigt.
(Genau, pumpen.)
Zeig doch mal deine Muskeln.
Ja, zeig mal, was du hast, Emanuel.
Ist mir peinlich.
Okay, dann nicht.
Was hast du heute noch so vor, Emanuel?
Wie feierst du mit uns?
Feier ich mit euch?
Ja, vielleicht, ich weiß ja nicht, was los
ist.
Ich habe überlegt, ob ich Fußball gucken
gehe oder nicht, aber das Spiel ist ziemlich
spät und ich wollte eigentlich früh schlafen
gehen.
Das Spiel ist doch um neun.
Ja, aber das dauert ja dann ein bisschen.
Und dann nach Hause … Weiß ich nicht, war
einfach, bin nicht so entschieden.
Ja.
Hast ja noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Ich bin zu laut.
Du hast … Chris schreibt hier gerade geheime
Regieanweisungen, behind the scenes, dass
Emanuels Stimme ein bisschen lauter ist.
Macht nichts, Emanuel, wir freuen uns so sehr,
dich zu hören.
Ja, du hast jetzt noch eineinhalb Stunden,
um dich zu entscheiden, sag ich mal, dann
musst du Bescheid wissen, ob du guckst oder
nicht guckst.
Aber ich freue mich, dass du mit uns feierst
auf jeden Fall.
Bist du gerade in deiner Küche oder wo sitzt
du da?
Nee, ich bin an meinem Schreibtisch.
Ah, und ich sehe, du hast da hinten so eine
Stange in der Tür, wo man so Sportübungen
machen kann.
Ah ja, genau, die ist aber … oh, was ist
denn jetzt los?
Ach so, also die Stange ist nur dafür da,
um meine Wirbelsäule zu … wie sagt man,
decompress?
Entlasten.
Dekomprimieren.
Dekomprimieren, ja, weil ich ein bisschen
Probleme mit der Bandscheibe habe.
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Und da hänge ich mich ab und zu an diese
Stange.
Krass.
Da drücken wir dir die Daumen, dass …
Ist alles in Ordnung, ist nicht so, nicht
so schlimm.
Gut, Emanuel.
Wie heißt noch mal deine Website?
Habe es schon wieder vergessen, your…
Yourdailygerman.com.
Genau, das ist eine sehr gute Website.
Merk dir das doch mal, Mensch!
Schaltet sie ein.
Nein, ich bin doch sogar Abonnent, E-Mail…
Newsletter-Abonnent.
Das möchte ich auch mal werden.
(Gut.)
Emanuels Lieblingsabonnent.
Emanuel.
Es freut uns sehr, dass du da warst, Emanuel.
Danke, dass du mit uns feierst.
Prösterchen!
Sehr gerne.
(Bis bald.)
Ciao, viel Spaß noch!
Ciao.
So, da haben wir noch mal Zeit kurz für eine
Frage, und zwar hat reupload — das ist der
Username — geschrieben: "Manuel hat sich
auch mal mit einem Spitznamen vorgestellt.
Erinnert ihr euch dran?"
Und zwar hast du damals gesagt: "Yo, André
Monet hier."
Das war ein … (Das war eine …) ja?
Eine Super Easy German-Folge, das Skript stammte
von Isi, die natürlich den Schnösel, wie
man sagt, also den reichen, unsympathischen
Vermieter, mir zuge… wie sagt man?
Diese Rolle hat sie mir zugeteilt und …
Wieso natürlich?
Wieso ist das deine … Isi …
Weil das war … das war ein "natürlich"
im Sinne von: Natürlich musste ich dafür
herhalten, aber am Ende hat es gut funktioniert.
Ja, richtig.
Das Video können wir ja noch mal verlinken,
wo du dich sehr offiziell am Telefon gemeldet
hast.
Ja.
Und Isi schreibt dazu: "Ich wusste einfach,
dass du das kannst, Manuel."
Toll.
Manuel, wen rufen wir denn als Nächstes an?
Jetzt könnten wir zum Beispiel mal die Nora
anrufen.
Oh, da bin ich gespannt.
Wir haben sie vor Kurzem live gesehen, wir
beide zusammen.
Richtig, und mit ihr haben wir …
Nämlich an deinem Geburtstag.
Stimmt.
Und mit ihr haben wir unter anderem über
Design gesprochen und über Stadtkinder und
Landkinder.
Hallo, hier ist Nora?
(Hallo Nora.)
(Hallo.)
Hi, das ist ja eine Überraschung.
Hallo, hier ist der Easy German Podcast.
(Na?)
Ist das wirklich eine Überraschung?
Ich glaube schon, ja, nein, Quatsch.
Ich habe nur so getan.
Wir haben alle Leute natürlich vorher eingeweiht.
Das wäre ja sonst ein bisschen fies.
Ja, das stimmt, aber ich freue mich umso mehr.
Wie geht es euch?
Gut, wie geht es dir?
Sehr gut.
Ich liege ganz gemütlich hier auf meiner
Couch und habe mich schon sehr gefreut auf
euren Anruf und wollte euch auch gratulieren
für die zweihundertste Folge.
Das ist ja ganz schön doll schon, oder?
Das ist doll, doll, doll.
Das ist ganz schön doll, Nora.
Dann sage ich mal: Prost!
Hast du auch ein Bier geholt vielleicht?
Oh, ich habe mir einen total … natürlich,
ich trinke ja kein Bier, also obwohl schon
manchmal, aber ich habe mir einen Wein gekauft,
einen Rosé, und da stoße ich jetzt mal hier
mit euch an einfach.
So kennen wir dich.
Ein …
Richtig.
Genau, ein edler Tropfen.
Einigen aufmerksamen Zuschauern ist übrigens
aufgefallen, dass ich glutenfreies Bier trinke,
das keinen besonderen Grund hat, außer, dass
ich Gluten versuche zu vermeiden.
Es ist allerdings offenbar niemandem aufgefallen,
dass Manuel alkoholfreies Bier trinkt.
Ich verstecke auch immer das Label, allerdings
nicht wegen der Marke, sondern … nee, nicht
wegen dem alkoholfrei, sondern wegen der Marke,
aber ich trinke schon seit längerem kein
… hat nicht so wirklich funktioniert mit
der Marke, ne?
Wir sind jedenfalls von keiner Biermarke gesponsert.
(Nee.)
Ja, ich trinke fast nur noch alkoholfreies
Bier, weil man dann keinen Kater hat am nächsten
Tag.
Ja, das finde ich eigentlich, ist sehr gut.
(Ist eine gute Idee.)
Ja, das stimmt.
Mache ich trotzdem nicht.
Ja, Nora, guckst du gleich noch Fußball?
Also ich glaube, eher nicht, tatsächlich,
aber weil ich auch kein Fußballfan bin, aber
jetzt … ja, vielleicht doch.
Also kommt drauf an, wie ich mich jetzt gleich
fühle, aber grundsätzlich eher nicht so,
nee.
Interessant, oder, Cari?
Dass alle so unentschlossen sind, ob sie Fußball
gucken.
Was ist denn das für eine Frage?
Natürlich guckt man Fußball.
Na ja, also ich muss sagen, das können wir
ja, das ist ein großes Thema, aber ich … wenn,
dann würde ich es halt gucken, um zu schauen,
ob nicht doch das Stadion heute erleuchtet
ist in Regenbogenfarben.
Ja, das ist, wird, glaube ich, nicht mehr
passieren.
(Nicht der Fall sein.)
Ja, Nora.
(Na gut.)
Bis bald!
Hab einen schönen Abend.
Ja, genau, und … Genau, und genießt noch
die Zeit.
Ich gucke es mir jetzt auf YouTube auf jeden
Fall an, ne?
(Machen wir.)
Danke schön, Nora!
(Bis dann, ciao!)
Bis bald, ciao.
Ciao.
Ja.
Sollen wir Klaus noch mal versuchen?
Bin mal gespannt, wie es bei ihm jetzt aussieht.
Eine gute Frage, mal schauen, wie die Lage
jetzt ist.
Jemand mit dem … Oh, warte, das lese ich
gleich vor.
Hallo!
(Hallo!)
(Na?)
So, jetzt geht es.
Wie sieht es aus?
Wie ist die Lage bei dir?
Jetzt besser.
Erst mal ganz herzlichen Glückwunsch!
Zweihundertste Folge, wunderbar.
(Danke.)
Ich freue mich sehr.
Ich habe, ich schätze, ein Viertel bis die
Hälfte habe ich gehört.
Wow, das ist ein Kompliment für uns, Klaus!
Ja.
(Ja.)
Wie geht es euch?
Was macht ihr gerade?
Hahahaha.
Nichts.
Nichts Besonderes eigentlich.
Wir sitzen hier rum und rufen Leute an.
Sehr schön.
Ja, ich habe, als ihr gerade anrufen habt,
habe ich gerade Lena ins Bett gebracht.
Sie war schon ein bisschen müde, deswegen
so ein bisschen laut, genau.
Und jetzt haben wir uns eigentlich grad vor
den Fernseher gesetzt und gucken einen Live-Podcast
von euch.
Da ist aber ganz schön viel Vogelgezwitscher
bei dir vor dem Fernseher.
Ja, ich bin jetzt kurz rausgegangen, weil
ich habe ja von Manuel gelernt, so was gibt
sonst Rückkopplung, wenn ich jetzt davor
telefonieren würde, ne?
(Sehr aufmerksam, Klaus.)
Von daher.
Genau, ja.
Ansonsten, unser heutiges Highlight war, Cari,
du weißt das vielleicht, Ursula hat sich
ja von dir und von Isi oder von Martin inspirieren
lassen.
Wir haben jetzt auch einen Saugroboter, der
heute jetzt zum ersten Mal durch unsere, unser
Erdgeschoss gefahren ist, und es war ein Highlight
für die ganze Familie.
Das … großartig.
Was ist denn passiert?
Was hat der Saugroboter aufgefressen?
Ja, der … nachdem er auf… das noch nicht,
aber er … Lena hatte viel Freude, hinterherzulaufen,
und der ändert ja dann die Richtung, wenn
man davorsteht, und das war … war auf jeden
Fall sehr lustig, ja.
Ja.
Ich würde mal sagen, wenn die Kinder im Haus
sind, dann wird der Boden nicht so sauber,
weil dann ist, ja, dann ist zu viel Spaß
im Spiel.
Ja, Ursula hatte schon die Idee, dass der
das dann nachts machen sollte, also dass der
nachts oder abends angestellt wird oder vormittags,
wenn hier auch freie Bahn ist, genau.
Gute Idee.
Manuel, kaufst du auch noch einen?
Ja, guckt ihr heute Abend das Spiel?
Ja, natürlich gucken wir das Spiel, ne?
Wir haben das gerade auch schon ein paar Leute
gefragt und einige Leute waren sich noch nicht
so sicher.
Und also die, die jetzt nur zuhören, die
haben dann nicht gesehen, wie kritisch Cari
dann doch geblickt hat.
"Wie, ihr seid euch nicht sicher, ob ihr das
Spiel schaut?
Das gehört ja wohl, das ist eine Bürgerpflicht."
Ja, so schlimm auch nicht, aber ich gucke
das Spiel.
Manuel, guckst du denn das Spiel?
Ja.
Ich schau mir das auch an.
Ich bin ja sonst kein Fußballfan.
Ich erinnere mich da an eine Episode über
Fußball.
Richtig, richtig, aber so Länderspiel in
der Europameisterschaft, das gucke ich mir
natürlich schon an.
Das ist doch schön.
Das wird bestimmt auch ein schönes Spiel,
davon gehe ich aus.
Das denke ich auch.
Klaus, komm bitte bald zurück in unseren
Podcast.
Ja, gerne, also, wirklich toll, was ihr da
macht.
Ich wünsche euch alles Gute für die nächsten
zweihundert Folgen natürlich.
(Danke.)
Und habt noch viel Spaß jetzt beim Telefonieren.
Machen wir, haben wir.
Bis bald!
(Ciao ciao!)
Ciao!
Ciao, Klaus!
Ich schicke Klaus die ganze Zeit Herzen, aber
der sieht mich ja gar nicht am Telefon.
Thao Le hat geschrieben: "In Vietnam ruft
man an Silvester Freunde und Verwandte an,
so wie ihr das jetzt macht."
Also wir feiern gerade eigentlich ein vietnamesisches
Silvesterfest.
Cool.
(Cool, oder?)
Pia.
Oh, Pia!
Pia rufen wir gleich an?
War in Episode 69 und 70 bei uns zu Gast und
hat uns über Krankenpflege in Deutschland
erzählt.
Und früher war sie natürlich auch in sehr
vielen Easy German Videos.
Mal schauen, was sie gerade macht.
Hallo!
(Hallo!)
Alles Gute zur zweihundertsten Folge!
Hallo Pia!
Wie brav alle gratulieren, ne?
Echt?
Habe es mir schon gedacht, dass ich nicht
die Einzige mit der Idee bin.
Pia, wie schön dich zu hören!
(Ja, gleichfalls.)
Wie geht es denn dir?
Gut.
Wir haben uns eigentlich seit unserer Podcastaufnahme
nicht mehr gehört.
Damals hattest du vor, nach Bayern zu ziehen,
oder?
Nee, nach Österreich.
Nach Österreich, nach Salzburg.
Und bist du jetzt da?
Ja, ich bin da.
(Wow.)
Ich wohne jetzt in Salzburg seit einem Jahr.
Moment, ist das grad hier ein Ferngespräch?
Das ist sozusagen ein Ferngespräch ins Ausland.
Krass.
Toll!
Wie ist es in Salzburg?
Sehr schön.
Sehr, sehr schöne Stadt, der Sommer ist hier
angekommen mit all seiner Wärme.
Und es gibt viele Seen, in denen man sich
abkühlen kann, was sehr, sehr gut ist.
Salzburg ist wirklich eine wahnsinnig schöne
Stadt.
Mathias kommt ja auch daher und wir haben
ihn schon mal besucht und auch ein Video dort
gemacht.
Und das ist so eine Stadt, die irgendwie so
unwirklich aussieht, oder?
So wie Disneyland, so ein bisschen.
Ja, ein bisschen.
Ja, also an manchen Orten ist es so, sieht
es so schön und zuckersüß aus, dass ich
manchmal denke, so: "So ganz echt kann es
doch nicht alles sein hier."
Aber es ist trotzdem sehr schön.
Sehr zum Genießen.
Und Studium ist gut?
Ja, wie geht es euch denn?
(Uns geht es …) Wie geht es euch mit der
zweihundertsten Folge?
Was ist das für ein Gefühl?
Es ist ein gutes Gefühl, es ist total entspannt.
Wir rufen Leute an, fühlen uns ein bisschen
wie im Radio, obwohl es ja YouTube ist und
Podcast, aber es macht Spaß.
Und es ist schön, euch alle zu hören, gerade
dich jetzt.
Das ist ja so lange her, dass du bei uns im
Podcast war (warst).
Das ist wirklich toll.
Ja.
Das ging jetzt irgendwie unglaublich schnell,
dass es schon die zweihundertste Folge ist.
Ich konnte das gar nicht glauben, als ihr
das geschrieben habt.
Krass, ne, was wir …
Mir kommt es zumindest so schnell vor.
Was wir hier raushauen.
Wann habt ihr diese zweihundert Folgen aufgenommen?
Nicht schlecht.
Jede Woche durchgepowert.
Fleißig, fleißig.
Ja, Pia.
Vielleicht hören wir uns bald mal wieder
im Podcast.
Ja, gerne.
Ich würde mich so freuen.
Eine schöne Jubiläumsfolge euch noch.
Ja, ich mich auch.
Und dann reden wir mal über das Medizinstudium.
Oh ja.
Da gibt es viel zu reden.
Toll.
Bis bald, Pia!
Genießt die Folge, schönen Abend noch!
Danke schön!
(Ciao.)
Bis bald, ciao!
(Ciao!)
Peter schreibt: "Janusz ist der König von
Easy German."
Das ist doch mal ein netter Kommentar, oder?
Kann ich so bestätigen, ja.
Ja.
Wen rufen wir als Nächstes an?
Als Nächstes, würde ich sagen, rufen wir
an … Aki.
(Haben wir noch …) Auch …
Aki, ach, geil.
Aki, auch schon in drei Episoden zu Gast gewesen
und … mal schauen, ob er rangeht.
Ja, hallo?
(Ja, hallo?)
Guten Tag!
Hi Aki!
Hey Aki!
Na?
Wie geht es euch?
Cari, wie fühlst du dich?
Sehr gut.
Wir haben uns ja gestern noch gesprochen,
ne?
Da, ich habe das eben erzählt hier.
Ich bin ans Telefon gegangen, unbekannte Nummer,
und da melde ich mit, mich mit "Carina Schmid?".
Und dann hörte ich auf der anderen Seite:
"Hallo, hier ist Aki, wo ist denn dein Arzt?"
Genauso ist es abgelaufen.
Diese Story müsst ihr jetzt erklären.
Ja, ich war nämlich gestern beim Arzt, um
geimpft zu werden, und dann habe ich gehört
beim Arzt, wie dort gesagt wurde, dass es
dort zwei Impfungen übrig gibt und sie hatten
keine Leute mehr, die die haben wollten.
Und dann kam die Arzthelferin ganz aufgeregt
und sagte: "Kennst du vielleicht noch jemanden,
der geimpft werden möchte?"
Und ja, dann haben wir alle Leute angerufen
und du warst dann der Glückliche, Aki.
Wir sind ja jetzt Impfpartner.
(Genau.)
Beim …
So sieht es aus.
Ihr habt den gleichen Impfgeburtstag.
Ja, ganz genau.
Und mit mir war noch ein junger Mann da, der
eigentlich auch noch geimpft werden wollte,
und ich habe tatsächlich die letzte Impfung
bekommen, dank dir, Cari.
Und es gibt ein wunderschönes Wort, wisst
ihr, wie eine geimpfte Person heißt?
(Nee.)
Impfling.
Impfling, ja.
Ja, wir sind jetzt frische Impflinge, Cari.
Das ist wunderbar.
Das hört sich schön an, Aki.
So was lernt man mit Kindern, genau.
Toll.
(Aki.)
Ja, ich finde es toll, dich zu hören.
Ich hoffe, wir treffen uns bald mal wieder
auf der Straße oder zufällig in einer Podcastepisode
demnächst.
Das könnte zufällig passieren.
Das wäre schön.
Bis bald, Aki!
Würde mich sehr freuen.
(Ihr Lieben, viel Spaß.)
Danke, dass du da warst.
(Ciao!)
Bis bald, ich mich auch!
Gerne.
(Ciao!)
Ciao.
Tschüss!
Das war nett mit Aki.
Das war sehr nett, wie immer.
Und ebenfalls nett ist unsere nächste Gästin,
unser nächster Gast, und das ist Nina, per
Video.
(Wow!)
Hallo Nina.
Spontan hier ein Video reingefahren.
Hallo Nina!
Hallo!
Alles Gute zur zweihundertsten Folge.
Mit Girlande oder wie nennt man das?
Ja, das ist eine Girlande.
Ich hatte kurz über Konfetti nachgedacht,
das ist eine saublöde Idee.
Hast du keinen Staubsaugerroboter?
Doch, aber auch zwei Kater, die fänden das
wahrscheinlich ziemlich interessant, das mal
zu probieren.
Verstehe.
Wie geht es euch?
Sehr gut, wie geht es dir?
(Gut.)
Auch, alles super.
Ich finde es schön, dass du extra was Visuelles
mitgebracht hast, heute live auf YouTube mit
einer Herzgirlande für uns.
Da fühlen wir uns sehr geehrt.
Und was hast du heute so gemacht, Nina?
Ich war heute nach einem Jahr mal wieder beim
Friseur.
(Oh.
Da musst du …) Ja, ich habe ein Jahr ausgehalten
und gewartet, dass das jetzt sicherer wird
und man keinen mehr anstecken kann und nicht
angesteckt werden kann.
Und heute war es soweit.
Es war sehr aufregend.
(Wahnsinn.)
Da freue ich mich auch drauf.
Meine Haare sind ganz lang, guck mal.
Wahnsinn.
Das ist Smalltalk, wie er in Deutschland geführt
wird.
Ja, und Wetter war ja auch, ne?
Wir haben noch nicht über das Wetter gesprochen.
War warm und jetzt ist es nicht mehr so warm.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Ja, es war schweineheiß die letzten Tage.
Es war richtig krass.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und in Hamburg war es vierzehn Grad kühler.
Wir sind an einem Tag von Hamburg nach Berlin
gefahren und hatten einen Temperaturunterschied
bei einer zweistündigen Fahrt von … glaube,
ja, vierzehn Grad.
(Krass.)
(Das ist krass.)
Das war ziemlich verrückt.
Liegt am Meer wahrscheinlich.
Vermutlich.
Ja.
Jetzt haben wir über das Wetter auch gesprochen.
(So.)
Schön.
Sehr gut.
(Check.)
Freut mich, wenn ich was beitragen konnte.
Das konntest du, wie immer.
Ja, Nina, bis bald!
(Ihr Lieben.)
Schön dich zu sehen.
Toll, dass du dabei warst.
Viel Spaß noch!
Bis bald.
Ciao.
(Tschüss.)
Ciao!
Manuel, wir haben eine, einen interessanten
Kommentar zum Thema Telefon von einem User
namens "Nur Ich".
Er oder sie schreibt: "Ich hasse das Telefon,
weil ich jahrelang im Kundendienst gearbeitet
habe.
Ich betrachte es als Instrument der Folter,
das vom Teufel erfunden wurde."
Ich habe das auch mal gemacht.
Ich war mal bei einem Marktforschungsinstitut,
als ich noch sehr jung war, und musste den
ganzen Tag Leute anrufen und sie überzeugen,
ein zwanzigminütiges Interview mit mir zu
machen.
Ich war relativ gut darin, muss ich sagen,
aber es ist, irgendwann hat man keine Lust
mehr zu telefonieren, das kann ich verstehen.
Ja, das kann ich auch verstehen, deswegen
… bei uns ist das nur Spaß, das mit dem
Anrufen.
Ganz locker.
Wollen wir mal Allaa anrufen?
Ja, sehr gerne.
Bekannt aus Episode 152.
Er hat mir gesagt, er wollte eigentlich per
Video dazukommen, er ist aber unterwegs.
Mal schauen, wo er gerade ist.
Hallo Manuel!
(Hallo Allaa!)
Hallo, hörst du mich gut?
Wir hören dich sehr gut.
Wo bist du?
Ich bin gerade in einer Kneipe, aber ich bin
jetzt rausgegangen.
Ich freue mich auf das Spiel von Deutschland
gleich.
Jawoll!
Jawollo!
Wo guckst du denn?
Ich bin in Schlesisches Tor in Berlin, das
ist eine Bar.
Das Leben kehrt so langsam zurück hier, ne?
Im Moment.
Ja, Mann, ich freue mich sehr.
Das ist echt … also man gewöhnt sich schnell
wieder dran, dass es einfach alles wieder
gut ist, aber trotzdem, ich versuche mich
jedes Mal zu erinnern, daran zu erinnern,
wie geil das ist, dass man wieder zusammen
sitzen kann und so.
(Das stimmt.)
Wie schön!
Und …
Und guckt ihr auch das Spiel gleich?
Wir gucken auch.
Was ist denn dein Tipp, Allaa?
Ich habe auf Deutschland getippt, drei - null.
(Gut.)
Das klingt realistisch.
(Das ist gut, ja.)
Dann drücken wir mal die Daumen.
Hast du Geld gewettet oder … du hast gesagt:
"Ich habe gesetzt"?
Nee, das ist einfach so unter Freunde(n),
wir, also schon Geld, aber unter Freunde(n)
und am Ende dann, wer alles so gewinnt an
Punkten.
Verstehe.
(So, so.)
Da kommt schon der Krankenwagen.
Ja.
Da kommt der Krankenwagen.
Ist das zu laut für euch, oder …
Mitten in Berlin.
(Nee, passt.)
Nee, aber wir lassen dich jetzt zurück zu
deinen Freunden.
Genieß den Abend und bis bald!
Oh, das war es?
Bis bald!
Das war es schon, ja.
Wir müssen noch ein paar andere Leute anrufen.
Wir sind schon, wir haben schon überzogen.
Alles klar.
Dann danke für den Anruf, hat mich gefreut
und bis dann.
Bis bald.
Es hat uns total gefreut, viel Spaß heute
Abend!
Danke!
Ciao ciao!
Ciao!
(Ciao!)
Herrlich.
Toll, toll, toll.
(Toll, toll, toll.)
Keith möchte, dass wir beide einen Whisky-Shot
trinken.
Da bin ich leider raus.
Ich habe auch keinen Whisky zu Hause.
Ja, ich schon, aber ich kann ja jetzt nicht
aufstehen, Keith.
Das verstehst du wahrscheinlich.
Ich trinke dafür noch einen Schluck Bier
auf dich.
Ja.
Ja, dann, wir nähern uns so langsam dem Ende
unserer Telefonliste für heute.
Aber diejenigen von euch, die uns schon sehr
lange verfolgen, können sich vielleicht erinnern
an Sarah, mit der wir in Episode 13 gesprochen
haben über das Thema Privileg.
Und ich glaube, sie ist in Köln und wir rufen
sie mal an.
Da kommt Janusz gerade mit einem Shotglas
rein, damit ich doch noch was trinken kann.
Oh, stopp!
Ein großer Shot.
Auf Keith.
Geht keiner ran.
Handy ist auch noch ausgegangen zwischendurch.
(Deins?)
Nur das Display.
(Hi!)
Hi!
Sarah meldet sich immer so am Telefon.
(Hallo!)
Sagt immer: "Hi!"
(Hi!)
Ich hatte mal einen Freund, der hat sich immer
so: "Und ich bin …", mit seinem Namen gemeldet.
Das war auch ganz großartig.
"Hi!
Ich bin Sarah."
Das ist gut.
Das mache ich vielleicht in Zukunft auch so.
Das ist ja toll.
Oder: "Hi!
Ich bin Manuel Salmann."
Ja, genau.
Hi!
Ich bin Carina Schmid.
Wunderbar.
Was machst du gerade, Sarah?
Ich bin gerade im Garten und habe mit Luca,
meinem Sohn, zusammen die Pflanzen gegossen.
Das klingt so toll.
Das ist schön, ja.
Ja, und dann kam er herausgerannt und hat
mir das … kam er vorbeigerannt und hat mir
das Handy, das ich natürlich auf dem Tisch
habe liegen lassen, hinterhergetragen.
Alles gut also.
Wer verbringt mehr Zeit auf YouTube, Luca
oder du?
Luca.
Das habe ich mir gedacht.
Ja, eindeutig Luca.
Bei TikTok könnten wir gleichauf sein.
Wirklich?
Wusstest du, dass wir jetzt auch auf TikTok
sind?
Nein!
Das muss ich sofort …
Ich nenne das immer TikTak, weil ich nicht
mal weiß, wie man es richtig ausspricht,
aber wir sind jedenfalls auch dort mittlerweile.
Sehr gut.
Das muss ich mir genauer angucken.
Aber das bietet sich ja auch total an.
"@easygerman", da findest du uns.
Sehr gut.
Ja, Sarah, und sonst?
Ja, gerade scheint die Sonne, aber es ist
nicht super heiß, also bin ich erst mal zufrieden.
Das ist schön.
Stellt mir spannende Fragen lieber.
Ja, wir stellen typische Smalltalk-Fragen,
wie man so in Deutsch, auf Deutschla… in
Deutschland, auf Deutsch redet.
Man fragt: "Und sonst?"
Und damit kann man alles Mögliche meinen.
Und du sagst: "Die Sonne scheint."
Genau, das ist ja auch …
Aber das sind tatsächliche Themen, ne, die
wir besprechen.
Das ist ein wichtiges Thema im deutschen Smalltalk,
würde ich sagen.
Das Wetter, bloß keine Politik, Fußball.
Ja.
Stimmt, haben wir eigentlich heute genau so
gemacht.
Ja.
Das denke ich mir.
Das bietet sich ja auch an.
Okay, dann ist unsere letzte spannende Frage
an dich: Wie geht das Deutschlandspiel gleich
aus?
Ich weiß, dass du das auch mitfiebern wirst.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass Deutschland gewinnt.
Ich sage drei - eins.
Okay.
(Ja.)
Sehr gut.
Klingt gut, Sarah.
Sarah, es war sehr schön, dich zu hören.
Es war sehr schön, mit euch zu sprechen.
(Bis bald.)
Danke, dass ihr mich angerufen habt.
Bis bald, habt noch viel Spaß.
Sehr gerne, hab einen schönen Abend.
Ciao!
Ihr auch, ciao!
Danke, ciao!
Manuel, ich habe noch eine letzte Zuschauerfrage
für dich.
Und zwar kommt die von Creighton.
Er schreibt: "Mit Freunden, schreibt ihr lieber
über SMS oder telefoniert ihr lieber?
Oder kommt es auf den Freund an?"
Kommt auch auf die Situation an.
Also ich mache auf jeden Fall mehr schreiben
und Voice-Nachrichten als telefonieren.
Und du?
Ich auch alles gemischt.
Es gibt auch manche Leute, mit denen ich gerne
telefoniere.
Voice-Nachrichten habe ich früher gehasst,
mittlerweile finde ich es gut, weil man damit
diese Zeit füllen kann, die man so zwischendurch
hat, die man für nichts nutzen kann.
Und für ein Telefonat fehlt mir dann manchmal
die Zeit, weil dann möchte man ja auch nicht
nach fünf Minuten sagen: "So, ich muss jetzt
weg."
Und ja, da ist das auf jeden Fall immer eine
gute Mischung.
Ich schreibe aber auch viel.
Alles mache ich gleichzeitig.
Manuel, haben wir noch ein Gast?
Unser letzter Gast ist mein guter Freund Tobi
und er ist per Video dabei.
Wow!
Oh, huiuiui.
Ich bin ein bisschen laut.
Du bist sehr laut.
Moment, das müssen wir aussteuern.
(So besser?)
Oh, so ist sehr gut.
Sehr gut?
Ja, hervorragend.
(Hallo Tobi.)
Du bist ja in einem richtigen Tonstudio da,
Tobi.
Ich bin in meinem Schlafzimmer-Homerecording-Studio.
Homestudio.
(Homestudio.)
Hier werden die Songs aufgenommen, die ihr
demnächst auf Spotify hören kann, könnt.
Stimmt das?
Das, ja, ja, bald, irgendwann, ja.
Und auf anderen Streamingdiensten.
Richtig, richtig, richtig.
Schön, euch zu sehen!
Schön, dich zu sehen!
Was machst du gerade so?
Ich komme von der Arbeit und jetzt habe ich
hier auf euch gewartet und mir euren, eure
Jubiläumsfolge angeguckt und das auch sehr
genossen.
Wie schön!
Hast du auch schon ein Bier aufgemacht?
Nee, nee, habe ich nicht.
Du trinkst eigentlich auch, wenn noch, wenn
überhaupt, nur alkoholfrei, oder?
Ich trinke fast gar keinen Alkohol, ja.
So gut wie gar nicht.
Ja.
Sehr gut, ihr seid alle sehr brav.
(Enthaltsam.)
Finde ich toll.
Tobi, was geht, was geht denn so bei dir?
Wann kommt dein nächstes Album raus?
Wie läuft es bei dir?
Mein nächstes ist ja mein erstes und das
kommt vielleicht dieses Jahr schon raus, wer
weiß?
Also es ist jetzt wirklich endlich soweit.
Und vielleicht auch erst Anfang nächstes
Jahr, aber bin gerade tatsächlich ziemlich
am Arbeiten daran.
(Geil.)
Ich bin am Arbeiten dran, ja.
Ich freue mich drauf, ja.
Habe ich gar keine falsche Frage gestellt
hier.
Nee, das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Hier, alles da, Instrumente stehen bereit.
Ja, ich habe auch Bock darauf.
Geil.
Ich habe auch Bock darauf, dein Album zu hören.
Ich kriege manchmal Previews zugeschickt von
Tobi über eine Audionachricht und darf dann
Feedback geben.
Und das ist ein sehr schönes Privileg, das
ich habe, ja.
Toll!
Ja, Tobi, wir müssen schon Schluss machen,
aber es war schön …
Ja, schade, aber es war schön.
Schön, dich zu sehen und zu hören.
Schön, mit dir zu feiern hier.
Ja.
Bis bald!
Danke, dass du da warst!
(Ciao!)
Gerne, bis dann, ciao!
Manuel, das …
Cari.
War eine sehr schöne und eine sehr außergewöhnliche
Episode.
Das können wir mal öfter machen, Leute anrufen.
Hat das so funktioniert, wie du dir das vorgestellt
hast?
Ja, nur, dass wir nicht genug Zeit hatten
mit allen und … (Das stimmt.)
Aber anrufen könnten wir doch mal öfter
machen, oder?
Total.
Und ich denke, wenn wir das nicht gerade live
auf YouTube machen, dann können wir Leute
tatsächlich überraschen einfach mal.
Die können dann ja immer noch später sagen,
sie wollen nicht.
Wir wollen natürlich nicht ohne Einverständnis
etwas ins Internet stellen, das ist klar,
aber das können wir wirklich mal machen.
Das machen wir.
Es fragen noch einige Leute: Warum haben wir
nicht Jeremy angerufen und warum haben wir
nicht Mathias angerufen?
Das machen wir dann hoffentlich beim nächsten
Mal, unsere guten Freunde.
Wir konnten heute nicht alle anrufen, aber
wir freuen uns, dass so viele dabei waren.
Und ich fand es, es war ein tolles Jubiläum.
Es ging ganz schnell vorbei, weil wir mit
so vielen Leuten gesprochen haben.
Fand ich auch.
Wenn ihr unsere schwierige Arbeit, die wir
hier vollrichten, unterstützen wollt — tatsächlich
gehört ja viel dazu — dann werdet doch
ein Mitglied auf Patreon.
Das hilft uns ungemein, für ein paar Euro
im Monat könnt ihr dort ein Mitglied werden,
dann bekommt ihr auch noch Bonus-Content und
Übungen und Transkripte und sehr viele Sachen,
die beim Deutschlernen helfen.
Wir würden uns wirklich sehr freuen.
Und das war es.
Und danken allen von euch, die schon dabei
sind.
Danke an unsere ganzen Patrons, die uns helfen,
dieses Projekt beruflich zu machen.
Und ihr habt auch diese zweihundert Episoden
möglich gemacht und das freut mich sehr.
Auf euch jetzt ein abschließendes: "Prost!"
(Prost!)
Prostikowski, Manuel.
Ich habe das Outro ganz vergessen.
Bis bald!
Oh, spiel das mal.
(Ciao!)
Ciao, liebe Leute, bis bald!